welcome to another episode of truth be
told and um today um we're going to be
talking about some of the um the da
activities here in the UK and also in
America as well and um we're also going
to be discussing some some very
important uh prudent issues
um in this time with regards to a lot of
new Muslims accepting Islam a lot of
influential people alhamdulillah by of
Allah accepting Islam and um we have
with us obviously special guest first of
allali welcome
back for for being here we
got
well for being here so um so thanks guys
for coming I know you have a very very
tight schedule so we'll we'll just get
straight into it uh so I think um um she
Hassan if you could um maybe give us a
bit bit of overview um with regards to
some of the da activities some of the
updates in terms of the success of the
da tables um in in German toown also
here in in in Cardiff as well um and
also um you know some of the um the new
Muslims accepting Islam and and how how
has things been since the last time we
we um we did we did a discussion here in
in since the last time
alhamdulillah a lot of things have
happened in Ramadan alhamdulillah Allah
subhana tala he blessed us we purchased
a church in
Philadelphia to turn into a Masjid
that's the goal the long-term
goal in addition to
that we had over 300 people Embrace
Islam all colors all walks of
life from various
backgrounds alhamdulillah accepting
Islam either at the da table or at the
Masid and I think that even here in the
UK I saw some of the videos with shami
and some of the other brothers a large
number of people embracing the religion
of Islam ald and I think that some of
the
reasons for these people embracing the
religion of Islam is because Islam has
many solutions and answers for them in
their personal
lives so alhamdulillah it's a good time
masab the da is growing it's spreading
there's so much positive things to talk
about you know and discuss insh
tal what about yourself sh alhamdulillah
West Lon alhamdulillah the brothers
reward them doing a great job
I mean we doable every Friday
alhamdulillah so at least one or two
people accept Islam Allah I mean
sometimes we have seven people sometimes
more sometimes less so you can see
people coming towards Islam even though
as I've mentioned many times there is a
huge war against Islam uh but yet Islam
is the fastest growing origion on the
face of the Earth why as our Hass
mentioned
Islam has solution for everything
alhamdulillah so likewise in the mid
inah we have classes now classes and
even we started uh I believe two months
ago new class for new Muslims
alhamdulillah our brother Muhammad
Somali alhamdulillah teaching Arabic
Basics alhamdulillah and all the class
are free likewise in ger alhamdulillah
that's good though to have a class for
new Muslims cuz then you knowly we we
always talk about them learning the
religion and and it's good to have like
a program for them as well yes yes you
have to have a system even when we
visited last year and one of the things
that the he stressed similarly before
him and many others is the followup
after somebody Embraces Islam
maintaining contact with them because
it's about growth and development and as
shami mentioned alhamdulillah even at
the Masid in German town we have Sunday
which is basically for beginners and new
Muslims so teaches the brothers and one
of the sisters mallah the wife of our
brother ABD
Kim she teaches the sisters
alhamdulillah they go through the book
that was written by comprehensive guide
for the new Muslim very good book very
good book you know when somebody
Embraces Islam what we were doing and we
continue to do is take their name and
their contact information yeah so you
know for the brothers Brothers reach out
for the sisters sisters reach out also
we have a telegram group you know for
new Muslims to maintain that you know
contact with them to help them you know
navigate along the way because they have
to learn it's very important that
alhamdulillah after embracing Al Islam
that they learn about the fundamentals
of the religion the pillars of Islam the
pillars of Im so that they can grow and
develop you know and contri contribute
to the umah that's very important that
shows the the love and the consent for
the
the the the Muslims for the new Muslims
you know for the mass and subh it's not
about just making a video Someone Tak no
it's about making sure his open no one
is perfect of course takes time but you
try your best to help them you know
alhamdulillah I think I think just the
point I was going to mention is that
obviously like a lot of the new Muslims
like some of them they go through
difficulty after accept in Islam like
some of their families disown them or
you know they they have animosity
towards them so so it's good for them to
have a community around them and I think
I think I think you know people talk
about Community General they say oh yeah
the Muslim is a community yeah we are
one um all of that but to have I think
um I was going to go come to you with
that to have established Mass on the
ground and you know da on the ground
with with with mass with lessons with
with a base where people can come is is
definitely beneficial very important
because you know visiting alhamdulillah
the Masid is excellent like you said
after the Masid where do you go who do
you socialize with many times new
Muslims are ostracized by their families
on when we're celebrating with our
families what are they doing imagine the
feeling that you go to alhamdulillah you
go to the everyone goes back to their
families but you have the non-muslim
family for example and you have a new
Muslim who's amongst them what does he
do or what does she do and that's what
we try and accommodate as well to make
sure is something you know for everyone
because the growth of the community you
have to also factor in the community and
consider you know their
wellbeing and um okay so just moving on
um the other question I was going to ask
was um what do you think um sh Hass
firstly come to you um what do what do
you think is the reason um or or maybe
maybe multiple reasons why a lot of
influential people um um are embracing
embracing Islam um I mean I mean
obviously we we see a lot of these
people that some of them are maybe
Sports personalities um some of them
they've embraced Islam at your own hands
and andah and U and at your Masjid as
well some of them could be celebrities
so that so they generally they have
wealth with them they have they have
some kind of status uh they have a big
following uh so you know like what is
their like what do you think and
obviously talking to them as well what
is the reasons for accepting Islam their
motives and and some of the I think that
knowing your purpose is one of the
greatest blessings that Allah tala
bestows upon an individual as Allah said
in the
Quran sometimes we take it for granted
we've heard it many times but it
resonates with the soul I have not
created the gin and Mankind except to
worship me alone to worship God alone
without any Partners we believe in one
God he is the Lord the Creator the
sustainer of everything and we worship
him alone
so like you said famous people rich
people you know poor people you can't
buy happiness that's something that
can't be purchased Fame you can't
acquire happiness through Fame you can't
acquire happiness through money and I
love these people like you said they're
wealthy they're famous but they're still
miserable so when you explain to them
Islam and what Islam offers because
Islam doesn't need any of us you know
it's very important for us to understand
that Islam doesn't need me he doesn't
need the most famous person on the
planet nor the richest person on the
planet it's like the verse in the
Quran they consider a favor upon you oh
Muhammad that they accepted at Islam say
to them you embracing Islam is not a
favor upon me rather Allah bestows his
favor upon those whom he chooses if you
are truly if you are truthful so they
need Islam in their lives we all need
every human being needs Islam in their
life for their spiritual well-being
likewise for the for the the
intellectual well-being and also for
their physical wellbeing and I think
that these people who are embracing
Islam they clearly understand it
yes what what what what would you add to
that shami I mean basically you I mean
you obviously been in touch with a few
few few influential people as well
giving them you know some some n some
some some you know reminders from here
there yeah like the mentioned Hass subh
Allah you can see they know having a lot
of money does not buy happiness and this
when
Allah and Allah mention the Quran that
the happiness in worshiping him subhah
waala so the true happiness because
sometimes yes you can get you can get
happy or some some Happiness by smoking
drugs doing har but that is a fake
happiness as the true happiness is when
you worship Allah when you understand
understand the purpose of your life you
know Subhan Allah so when you understand
the purpose of your life and you
understand you're here to worship Allah
and this life is an is a test then
Subhan Allah there suff within our body
nothing can fulfill it except when you
become a servant and a slave to the
creator of the heavens and the Earth and
which is in between
them said
they flee from the the the servitude
which they have been created for and
they become slaves of their desires and
societies and Shan so uh Subhan Allah um
regardless how much money you have
regardless how famous you are you will
never receive that true happiness until
you understand the purpose of your life
and you fulfill it according to the
Creator as well subhana tala and that's
why many people accepted Islam I mean in
Japan they say the happiest country in
the world is Japan and Sweden but guess
what the highest rate of suicide is
where in Japan and Sweden I mean like
how they happy meaning they get good
money good salary they have good houses
nice houses yeah public healthare and so
on but clearly that is not for making
them uh uh uh it's not giving them true
happiness otherwise why you going to
commit suicide so Subhan Allah yeah this
is Subhan Allah so H they know they
they've noticed because to be honest a
Christianity it doesn't not give
solution to mankind likewise Judaism is
a Judaism is like a tribal religion only
for specific tribe Christianity is like
just stay in the church believe in God
died for your sins you'll be saved but
Islam gives solution for every problem
Subhan Allah like Subhan Allah to deal
what with your intellect with your
spirits with your physical body likewise
with your social problems economical
economical problems and so on
alhamdulillah no that's that's good um
and also just a leading question onto
that fle um what what do you think are
the the specific challenges that these
influential people face after accepting
Islam obviously we talked about
generally Muslims or new Muslims accept
in Islam then they face certain
challenges we talk about a alization of
their families and things like that but
I think the the influential Muslim or
the celebrity Muslim is is a kind of a
unique situation what would you think
are the some of the the challenges that
they face I think some of the challenges
obviously Financial worrying about a
person's career worrying about Avenues
of income after they Embrace Islam
however again that's a test you know
Allah he
said whoever fears Allah will provide
for them a way out I'll give an example
um famous individual accepted Islam
alhamdulillah he contacted me and he
asked me I think he had an opportunity
to advertise it was either drugs
marijuana or alcohol and it was a test
this was maybe weeks or months after
embracing Islam and I told him I said
brother whenever you leave something for
the sake of Allah Allah will replace it
with that which is better but you have
to have that level of certainty you have
to leave it for Allah and you have to be
certain that Allah will replace it with
better Pati patience and there are
lawful
Alternatives there's more lawful money
out there than unlawful money but many
people can't see the big picture or they
don't have the confidence you know to go
forward so I explained that to him you
know may Allah T guide us and him you
know all of the Muslims so that's one
challenge you know I think Financial
worries also another worry that they
probably have will they lose some of
their Fame and their influence again
Shan you know the devil weaponizes these
things whereas in reality a legacy that
will lost is found in implementation of
Islam in the correct fashion look look
at Abu Bakr islamallah it raised them to
a degree that they are the best of man
kind after the prophets and The
Messengers look how Allah honored them
so I think also a challenge for new
Muslims learning the
religion you know I'm famous or I'm rich
why am I attending classes or why am I
visiting the scholars of Islam or why am
I you know asking questions of you know
the and I think that's a challenge for
them as well and I mentioned in one of
Myas what thean of uh yeah
teachers I mentioned in one of Myas in
America I said no one's too rich you
know to pray in the Masid or attend a
class it's very important that you learn
the basics of the Rel the foundations of
the religion to allows you know everyone
to grow so we worship Allah upon
knowledge we're not expecting people you
know to be Scholars and like shami
said people are going to grow you know
slowly but surely you know yes Allah
blesses some people it can be
instantaneous and that's a blessing from
Allah but many people it takes time
takes time right but the thing about it
is is that you know learning the
religion is something upon all of us
yeah no no one's exempt because that's
what distinguish is Isam from any
religion Islam is based upon and
knowledge and actions you know and uh
and I want to go back to the point which
we have to emphasize that we are in need
of Islam yes we are in need of Islam we
have to understand that and even the she
CAU in the verse which is beautiful
verse you're not doing favor to us by
becoming a Muslim you know is a fa from
Allah Allah blessed you so either you're
going to appreciate it yeah or you're
going to turn away from it and you're
going to be from the from the losers
from among the losers so you should
should be grateful to Allah that Allah
guide you to Islam the
word Allah is is a selfish is not in
need of nothing everything's in need of
him
ishal so um accepting Islam
alhamdulillah Shan will come to you and
thinking you're doing favor to the
Muslims or even saying look I give
charity and islamically when you charity
you keep it between you and yourself you
don't have to between you and Allah you
don't have to tell the whole world you
understand CU remember you're not doing
favor and Allah mentioned about those
who gives charity then they go and
expose themselves and
likewise rather is a narration and
mentioned there are seven types of
people that Allah will cover them with
the shade of his throne on the day of
Resurrection when the son is too close
to mankind one of them he gives Sak the
charity with his right hand even his
left hand doesn't know how much he give
so we have to be cautious
and one of the things I was going to say
as well M you reminded me of the point
is that we are delighted when anyone
accepts Islam whether we know them or
don't know them of course aldah whether
it's in the East or the West W I see
anyone Embrace Islam you know I'm happy
alhamdulillah delighted you know whether
they're famous or not famous whether
they're rich or poor even though they're
giv you nothing exactly you know and
certain you know influencers or famous
people I'm happy that they Embrace Islam
but I hope also that they go on to learn
the religion of Islam because that's how
they leave a legacy you
know what did he say he said we are
people Allah honored us with Islam when
we seek honor in other than Islam Allah
will humiliate us so it's important for
all of us to understand that point like
Shi mentioned Allah is Allah is the all
rich the one with no needs he doesn't
need any of us we need Allah subhana wa
tala and I think that as Muslims
sometimes we're too quick to elevate
people somebody Embraces Islam and
immediately they're on platforms giving
lectures which is
ludicrous it's like we have an
inferiority complex yes we are happy and
delighted whenever anyone Embraces Islam
however in order to talk about the
religion of Islam it requires
knowledge knowledge predes speech and
action and I think sometimes they set up
these people for
failure it's good point to mention that
cuz some people they always have a f of
Fame so before accepting Islam he had
that F he wants to become he wants to be
known he wants to be always in the front
line so you given him that when he's
becoming a Muslim you putting him into
another FNA Subhan Allah so so I can
utilize uh I can be famous even Islam
now it's dangerous Subhan Allah because
you know
is you can misguide
people subh Islam teaches us about
humbleness you know and understand the
servitude the meaning of servitude
likewise in Islam you know it's very
dangerous seeking fame or liking to be
known Subhan Allah there's one of
the you know he us to hate people coming
sitting with him like if if you notice
there's more than five sitting with him
he to G and walk away Subhan Allah so we
don't we don't seek Fame
if you're teaching and you become known
it's from Allah but always have to make
Dua to Allah to protect our hearts you
know Subhan Allah so and also being
famous for the right things you know
imagine like alhamdulillah you know a
person Embraces Islam you're famous or
you're rich but you attend the Masid you
go to the five daily prayers you fast
Ramadan you seek knowledge you know you
encourage others to do good these are
role models alhamdulillah in those good
actions the problem is when you become
famous and you still disobeying Allah
waala and you're still publicly
displaying those type of things you know
that's dangerous because like you said
it can influence you know vulnerable
people or people that look up to them
and they think that okay these sins or
you know these acts of Disobedience
they're okay and that's problematic as
well I mean just that's got leads on to
the other question I was going to ask is
like was obviously you know there when
when when these influential people they
they accept Islam there's there's a they
have a lot of um enthusiasm for for lack
of better word and they they want to to
um maybe do something and and they feel
that you know um Islam's giving me so
much and there's so much love coming
towards me from from various communities
and everything I want to give back I
want to do something and then and maybe
they want to get involved in dawa and
maybe they want to they want to you know
participate in in in the religion from
that perspective so what is the best way
for them to do that um I think would be
a good
question I mean Allah said in the Quran
say oh Muhammad this is my path I call
to Allah based upon knowledge based upon
understanding calling to Allah is
worship worship any act of worship in
order for it to be accepted by Allah has
to fulfill two conditions
sincerity and the second has to be in
accordance to the sun of the Prophet
sallahu wasallam so the enthusiasm is
good but we have to learn what am I
inviting to what am I calling to for
example right alhamdulillah Allah
blessed an individual to embrace
Islam he's saying I'm
Muslim or her however publicly they say
statements like Jesus Christ Our Lord
for example or statements that are
similar to that these statements are
statements of open disbelief
right this is not inviting to Islam
rather this even though a person may
have said it out of ignorance but the
danger is this is ignorance about the
foundation of the religion you know
about the meaning of
the so potentially can have a negative
effect upon others and it could you know
it could misguide others so the thing
about it yes I'm a Muslim I'm
enthusiastic I want to you know help
Islam and help the Muslims I think
knowledge is is vital like the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said the best
of them is is the the best of them in
Islam is the best of them in Jah as long
as they have understanding of the
religion that's very important
n if they gain understanding of the
religion and that's what alhamdulillah
there may be people out there mallah but
you will see the effect that people who
be who Embrace Islam or even people who
are Muslims and they're famous when they
implement the religion correctly you
will see the effect that these
individuals have by the will of Allah
waala and that's why even when certain
individuals Embrace Islam are very
cautious don't you know put a burden on
them that they can't bear like you're
comparing them to
or comparing
them comparing them to the 10 you
know have being given Glad Tidings of
paradise or comparing them to immed or
Islam give them time to grow and
develop and one of the things I would
say whoever's around them teach them
educate
them we have people who claim to be da
people when they they are utilizing
these uh brothers who are uh f
by pushing to give as
well knowledge proed action and
speech acknowledge have a knowledge
learn there's no one worthy of worthy of
worship in truth except
Allah Allah Mery
said knowledge preced action speech and
now what we see some new brothers or
reverts getting involved into debates
even organizing debates between Muslims
and the Christians and allowing this new
revers not the way of the qurnah that us
is to
learn that not to listen to doubts you
know what going to add is there debates
between enemies of Islam and Muslims
yeah not any not a Christian okay maybe
he's seeking the truth in but those who
are known to be enemy of Islam they just
bringing and doubtful matters and so on
and you putting them forward no it's not
good because why you are U utilizing
their platforms because they're
famous now is now to go and and and be
in movies when there's music when
there's is a by way of Revelation you
know it's better off if you make
mistakes say I made mistake Allah
forgive me but Subhan Allah what's
happening now in a DA SC is just
unbelievable Subhan Allah one of the
things I will say as well you know it's
a bit off topic yeah but um no it
relates to what we're talking about the
regular people as well who Embrace Islam
or not famous or maybe not rich me
personally in our community mallah the
things that they the sacrifice that I
witnessed from them is a lot greater
than maybe some people who are famous or
some people who are rich because
sometimes you know it appears you know
and Allah knows best some things are
just for social media or Instagram or
Tik Tok right when you see certain
things like being advertised all over
the world but you have individuals they
clean the Masid nobody knows them that
person in the community is as important
as anyone else you know the person in
the Masid that's you know teaching you
know the children how to read alab and
nobody knows them this is what helps
build communities and those are the
people Subhan Allah to be honest with
you whether they're rich whether they're
poor it doesn't matter whether they're
famous or not famous they these are the
people that will help build our
communities these are the people that
make the changes that we need in in the
umah as a whole and I think sometimes s
you know these people are undervalued
and I think that's dangerous as well
because this um it will be victorious
through who for the
week you know through their prayer
through their supplication MH you know I
think that's a point that we miss you
know it's like you know we Overlook
people in our midst Mah who are
sacrificing for the sake of Allah and
we're looking at you know somebody just
because they're famous or because
they're rich I think that gives a
dangerous message you know especially
for the young people to go back to the
point of them want to give d or they to
give back to the communities like the
mentioned do things which like you know
according to your abilities you know men
good point he said to give a DA is not
conditional that you have to be in the
front line or front of the microphone
addressing people giving da you clean
the mid you are helping the da printing
leaflet you are helping in da you know
it's no conditional to buy a phone
iPhone or any smartphone even retweeting
about a lesson or taking someone to the
lesson
taking inviting people to the lesson
yeah it comes to asking or the brothers
can I have a leaflet I'm at work so I'm
giving it you giving that so you don't
have to be on front of the camera
addressing the people and this is the
problem with these so-call da people may
Allah guide us and guide them they don't
understand they should teach these
brothers look you're a new Muslim we're
very happy that you become Muslim may
Allah bless you alhamdulillah but
there's a way Islam is from
Allah we're going to worship Allah
according to our desires and giving da
as mentioned is part
of and is based upon two
conditions
sincerity they have not been commanded
except to Allah
sincerely and imagine the effect that
you know one of these individuals you
know maybe who's famous or rich or
whatever now imagine they actually went
away and they studied or they went to
the University of Medina or they went to
some of the scholars they sat with
people like fan and they benefited from
them and then alhamdulillah they came
back and they gave da based upon their
ability Subhan Allah imagine the effect
that that would have upon the youth like
I said just attending lessons someone
seeing that you know M he attends
lessons he sits and he benefits you know
he asks the scholars
of you know and so on and so forth that
has a even that if your intention is
that you do it for the sake of Allah and
also alhamdulillah you want to encourage
others to do good you'll be rewarded for
that no that's um the other thing I
wanted to ask was um obviously um and
it's something that's that's good to
maybe clarify as well so if if you see
if if we have these new Muslims or um or
you know people that have embraced Islam
recently and they you know they're
influential Etc and they fall into these
errors um like as I mean as as you give
an example like you know making
statements that apparently could be
themed as as um disbelief and things
like that how what's what's the best way
to correct them uh what's the what's the
middle path uh around correction and
also advice and these kind of things I
mean the origin is gentleness and
kindness that's the origin to ad try and
advise them privately hopefully they
retract it and it doesn't become a
pattern without Shadow a doubt I don't
think anyone disagrees with regards to
that however we have to be be cautious
also
because if it is claimed that somebody
utters a statement of shik for example
that I call upon the de or you know I
worship the people in the grave or my
parents control yeah or my parents my
ancestors you know they control the
universe or they're going to protect me
and stuff like that right and it's not
corrected publicly by the individual
then this has the potential to misguide
unsuspecting Muslims and even
non-muslims who may be interested in the
religion of Islam
also if we look at the in the Quran of
the
Prophet Allah
said you're the best nation that has
arisen from mankind you enjoying what is
good and you forbid what is evil and you
believe in Allah there's no
differentiation between famous and not
famous Rich poor black white Arab
non-arab we enjoy what is good and we
forbid what is EV in light of the
guidelines of the Shar the prophet he
said whoever from amongst you sees an
evil then let him change
it change it with his hand if he's not
able then with his tongue if he's not
able then with his heart and that's the
lowest form of IM again in the
boundaries of
the the the danger is if we say that if
a famous person or a wealthy person
makes a public mistake a statement of sh
statement of kufur or statement that
clearly goes against andah and they're
not to be corrected if they don't
retract it and so on and so forth
also another danger you're opening the
door for
the the Hypocrites because the look
there people sit back no doubt there are
people they plot and they plan they had
Hypocrites at the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alai
wasallam they'll study what's taking
place in the world all you have to do is
claim to be a Muslim and you can say
whatever you want to say and nobody's
going to correct it yeah that could be a
precedence yeah exactly look how did
spread said can you imagine individuals
appearing and they were abusing the
sahab the best of mankind after the
prophets and The Messengers he said one
of the reasons it was the ignorance of
the people ignorance of the people
meaning you tolerate it you turn a blind
eye to it oh he's a new Muslim you know
he doesn't know somebody
abusing oh they don't know yeah yes no
doubt you advise them you clarify but if
they don't retract it then what then the
the clarification has to be public
preserving the over over any
individual Subhan Allah it's it's well
known and it's dangerous because also
the is like you don't want
this like if someone say and when
someone is famous is worse than someone
who is not famous because if he's famous
and has a followers the the followers
they think ah it's normal it's you know
there's many du they have not corrected
him so therefore is AD is okay you know
especially when you can see people
liking it with written it a clear C
statement and also says only for the
leaders to correct
them I mean this is I was going to get
to that point and and the thing about it
look right thei of the Prophet sallallah
alaihi wasallam that correction is based
on we want good for the individual it's
nothing personal M we don't want
anything from them we don't want any
thanks no Commendation we don't want
anything from them you know
alhamdulillah it's important to
understand as well that any correction
is based on Mercy Rah we want good for
the individual There's No Malice there's
no dislike it's important for us to
understand as well any correction is
based upon Mercy we want good for the
individual it's not based on malice and
the Hadith of the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam when he
said that whoever introduces an evil way
or an evil practice they will have the
sin of that and the one who acts upon
that until the day of judgment and there
is no difference between the sin so when
the correction is made in it will
prevent other people from following them
in that that's why one of the Sal they
said that you know we are more merciful
to the people of innovation than their
own parents their own mothers because
you know when we clarify the error
hopefully it will prevent others from
following that error and because if
somebody follows them in that error they
may have a sin and the burden of that so
when these things are corrected it's
because we want good for the the
individual and we want for them to come
back but the greater good is protection
of the um the de yeah yeah prot what
about some some of the people they they
say that you know the applying shid like
some some some element of harshness is
is just is is restricted to um when you
have a position of power or rulership I
mean IM if we look at the text we don't
find that in the text of the Quran and
the sun of the Prophet sallallahu alai
wasallam also
understanding of the
companions understanding of the
IM when the ruler was compelling people
to say that the Quran was created IM he
refused that he said the Quran is the
speech of Allah and created whoever says
the Quran is created is a
CF and he was imprisoned and he was
tortured and he was punished yes he
prohibited the people from rebelling
against the ruler no he said fear the
blood of the people fear the blood of
the people what we are experiencing is a
fidna a specific trial and test we don't
want to cause something that affects all
of the people Tom more for everyone
however stating what is correct Subhan
Allah to limit you know clarifying you
know what is good
clarifying forbidding evil the head the
greatest evil is sh that is only
restricted to people of authority Subhan
Allah I do not know any basis for that
in the Quran in the sun of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam or the
understanding of
theh I mean like um what's happening now
there are some brothers out there
especially with this U or they think
that salais are quote
unquote say but when we see some
brothers guide them pushing this notion
of even though he said a Cy statement
let's advise him or should advise him or
you have to do in in private and so
on if the person no and many times
individual has been advised privately
and how do they know that the person
hasn't been being advised privately
that's an assumption like uh some of the
S they said I didn't advise them because
you didn't hear
it so you know the the you have to uh
advise so it's not the it's not about
advising privately openly okay was schol
is a conditional in order for me to to
refute a ble I have to advise the person
privately
first
BH the
Maj where do you got the shirt
from if you know it's going to accept
and you are able to reach him then you
can do it alhamdulillah okay so the and
I fear men I Fe one day they going to
tell us listen you cannot advise these
influencers or these famous people you
have to do it privately because leaders
why you going startop bringing the of
concerning the Muslim leaders to these
influences as not like should do it
nicely you know you do it with wisdom
and wisdom doesn't not mean you have to
do it soft all the time rather some from
wisdom to do it in a harsh
way he became Muslim I believe was the I
believe the eighth or the sixth I can't
the year exactly but the same year he
became a Muslim and sent him to fight
against a tribe in arula Pagan tribe but
they accept Islam so he misunderstood
them and he thought they didn't not
accept Islam so he killed some of them
he when he came stood up openly and he
said
it literally just become Muslim maybe a
month before or two weeks before but yet
freed himself from the action Subhan
Allah so this notion of you have to just
become Muslim two years or one year
alhamdulillah we're happy for the
brother he become Muslim but we have to
advise him you know and protecting the
deed take prisons over protecting the
person's
honor especially if you have Muslims
liking the tweet and retweeting
it because even the first is what
preservation preservation of the Rel
religion mhm and one of the the means to
preserve the religion is clarifying
mistakes and errors that especially when
they made publicly yes alhamdulillah if
you can advise them privately
alhamdulillah but like shami mentioned
it's not a condition it's not a
condition and it's not a condition why
based upon the text of the Quran and the
Sunnah Subhan Allah even as it relates
to
some yeah right you see some of the
companions correcting others Subhan
Allah as it relates to what about
matters rela to
relating Subhan to talking big issues
isn't huge I mean look certain things we
understand some people are new Muslims I
don't know any of the students of
knowledge to have addressed certain
things which
are you know errors in light of the
Quran and the Sunnah but we understand
you know somebody's a new Muslim you
know it takes time for a person to
change however as it relates to the
foundation of the
religion or what opposes the statement
as it relates
you
know you
know these have to be clarified Subhan
Allah and and it it's it opens up
another D dangerous president because
later on when you you know mistakes that
whether it's Scholars whether it's you
know famous Muslims uh speakers when we
go to correct them then you have the the
groups and the parties they come back
and they say but you know you correct
these people with and they have an
influence they have millions of
followers he has 10 million followers
you know he has influence all over the
world how are you responding to him and
the error is not as severe but you know
you're making excuses for so and so it
opens up a dangerous
B that's why I said he open the door of
accusing someone saying cofy statement
openly tweeting it people liking it and
yet you say would do in private
I don't know which you have asked which
what we know based
upon that if someone says something
is you send
explanation yeah I mentioned the
explanation
of himself the explanation of
even also and many others Subhan Allah
and even Mash if you go back to the
explanations I couldn't because I wanted
it to be concise they even mentioned you
know the importance of you know being
stern is it relates to public errors
that oppose the Subhan Allah so so other
question I wanted to ask was probably
maybe um a tricky one was uh with
regards to um you know like people you
know saying that okay I'm a new Muslim
right but then maybe they've been
they've been they've been they've
accepted Islam for like five years six
years seven years and you know how long
can they actually be considered they
know under the criteria of a new Muslim
if there is such a criteria um you be
able to elaborate on that a little
bit as for the holding the new card of
the card of a new Muslim then has a nice
speech in
his addressing the issue
of excusing someone because of
ignorance likewise uh
spoke about in the of Islam because one
of the Islam
is away from the de so said we do not
give the excuse of ignorance to everyone
and all the time that there's conditions
to it one of the condition the person is
willing to learn but it doesn't have the
access to learn okay is willing but he's
trying his best to learn but he doesn't
have the access to
he said this person will be excused
because he's trying his best but as for
a person who has the ability to learn
and has access to of knowledge but he
chooses to not learn and he has he's
he's careless you know he said this
person should there's no excuse for him
so someone says you know uh they have
this the card of new Muslim for their
whole life for their whole life
because meaning that you're able toar
but you choose
like I don't care you know Subhan Allah
this dangerous I mean what we what we
see some people pushing this type like I
said so this is dangerous so we have to
be cautious and Allah protect us all for
no I think it's important to understand
as well that
this point that's being raised you know
it's baseless because I don't think
anyone has made upon the some of the
individuals they're referring to and
that's considering you know that maybe
they have a valid excuse
and specific individuals is for the
people of knowledge anyway however
refuting the statement whether they're a
new Muslim or they've been Muslim for a
year or 10 years or 20 years or 30 years
if a statement is a statement of kufur a
statement of sh and is affecting people
potentially publicly then it's to be
refuted to claim any differentiation
between the two you have to bring some
type of proof and
evidence so even that argument you know
they're a new Muslim or they've been a
Muslim for a year or two years or they
always remain you know a new Muslim
until they learn it's not
valid Theory I mean even
the it
mentions subh Allah new Muslims
was
even and it was
explain
explain but
yet freed himself from the action openly
let alone C statement and so may Allah
guide us and guide
him one of the they may say the prophet
was the ruler again yeah who
said address the rule of it okay um so
the next so next question I was going to
like maybe try to flip the script a
little bit is is like with regards to
like I mean I've heard statements people
say that you know if someone is um is is
you know obviously they their actions or
what they're involved in is cont is is
highly contrary to to Islamic practices
you know they're involved in a lot of
maybe maybe criminal activities or
activities that not befitting um of of a
Muslim and they want to now embrace the
religion of Islam um you know some some
people would say that you know you know
let's leave that don't give don't don't
don't let them Embrace Islam get let
them give them opportunity to change
some of their ways um and then and then
if you see that change taking place then
you know then then allow then you know
then then see if they're still
interested and then give them the the
the shahada um I mean I've I've seen
this being propagated as well so what
would you what would you say in response
to that is that correct stance or is
there is there um a more valid view on
this if somebody comes and the Shah you
know is explained to them the meaning
of I testify that none has the right to
be Worship in truth except
Allah I testify that Muhammad is the
messenger of
Allah and they understand the meaning
and they acknowledge that they believe
in what's being explained to them they
also you know they want to implement it
in their lives and they have a Zeal to
implement the religion of Islam you give
them the shahada I mean that's what we
find in the text of the Quran and the
sun of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam if for example thei of the
Prophet Sall wasallam when he
said whoever statement is obviously we
know he has
conditions from the conditions is
understanding the
meaning and
as mentioned when somebody says you know
in order to embrace that Islam you say
the sh upon your tongue that's the first
thing
likewise you understand the meaning of
the none has the right to be worship
truth except
Allah and you act upon that which it
necessitates from you then alhamd you
let them Embrace that Islam
inshal because if they come and they
want to embrace Al Islam and they
understand the Shah but they leave you
and then they go home and they die in
their bed may Allah protect us all from
that and they die upon disbelief me
personally I fear that I will be
questioned before Allah subhana T
concerning that that somebody was they
had a desire to embrace Islam they
understood that Shah was explained to
them they said this is what I believe I
believe in one God he's the Lord the
Creator the sustainer they believe in
the R I believe that only God is to be
worshiped alone without any Partners I
believe in all of the prophets and The
Messengers I do not believe that any of
the prophets and The Messengers have any
share of divinity they are human beings
like us but they are also Messengers
they are chosen by God as Messengers and
Prophets if somebody comes and they and
they want to embrace Islam and I say to
them no you have to go away and you know
change a lifestyle first
subh mention someone come to you take
and turn him away you become and even
the you know you know about the even if
he steals even if he
fornicates we know the the most
important thing is what the foundation
is the shahada again pronouncing it you
know understanding the meaning
implementing it but major sins lesser
than don't exit a
person the first you
to no tell them stop
everything and if they ask you if if
they ask you about certain things you
know what's the ruling of alcohol you
alcohol is forbidden what's the ruling
of zen zen is forbidden what's the
ruling of such and such this is
forbidden if they have the foundation of
Islam they take the Shah you know they
establish the five daily prayers in
their lives but they have shortcomings
if they die in that state if they die
even if they die
upon committing a Maj lesser
than they fall under the of Allah if
Allah chooses you'll punish them however
they will end up in however Allah
forgive
them that
stat so I think that you know we have to
be cautious yes we want people to change
and we encourage them to change but at
the same time to turn them back and say
you know we're not going to give you a
shahad until you change a b c and d
Subhan Allah I don't know any again any
proof of that and Allah knows best what
what what would you say about like some
of the recent um you know the the
activities we see online with some of
these um rappers or ex rappers they
they've um apparently accepted Islam and
then they're still participating in in
um in CRI gun crime and violence and and
things like that I mean we we people
some people might say that you know
they're they're not really they're not
really Muslim or they you know why are
they still participating in this I mean
the best thing first to give advice you
know this lifestyle of crimes and so on
that's dangerous and either is going to
lead you to prison or to the Grave
Subhan Allah
so uh like becoming a Muslim doesn't
mean you're going to become perfect M
like our was mentioning sh is the most
important thing which is be that's the
Islamic Quan teaches
us that's the most important thing like
Hadith of M yes so the best is to advise
them and to there's many examples that
we can see that when you are involved in
this uh lifestyle either as I mentioned
going to end up in a grave or you're
going to end up in prison Subhan Allah
and uh you know Shan will try everything
to destroy us MH so if you accept Islam
one of the advice that I can give to my
dear brothers out there I bless you all
make sure you have a good around you
good friends is very very important
Allah
thean that their friends they will be
enemies to each other except the
righteous ones Allah have mercy upon
mention his he said what is the meaning
of the Ayah that if you have a friend
you and him always helping each other to
do the to carry out worshiping Allah
going to measure together if one of you
pass away before the other one then you
ask Allah to keep him firm so Allah have
had a friend in this dun in the dun was
always encouraging me to worshiping you
oh Allah keep him firm as for then
mentioned if you have a friend always
you and him doing Haram if one of you
passes away before the other one then
that person will say oh Allah I had a
friend in the dun always was encouraging
me to do evil thing
Allah keep him upon his guidance so look
someone that you thought he was your
best friend in the he became your enemy
Subhan even Allah mention the Quran they
will be cursing each other Subhan Allah
so my advice to my brothers out there
have good friends will help you after
Allah's
Aid yeah I think also we have to
consider that these societal ills
existed before they embraced
Islam they were involved in certain
things that were detri Al to them in
this life and the Hereafter after they
embraced Islam yes they have to fulfill
the commands of Allah they have to stay
away from the prohibitions but no one
can blame Islam for the activities that
for example is taking place because they
were doing it before Islam but Islam if
they implement it correctly by the will
of Allah subhana tala will bring them
from the darkness to the light because
how many verses in the Quran Allah
mentions bringing the individuals from
dark Darkness to light right and the
scholars they explain it they say what
from the darkness of disbelief to the
light of Faith IM from the darkness of
to the light of from the darkness of
Disobedience to the light of obedience
so that's something that we have to
consider also these individuals we call
them to the Masid we're not going to
attend any conferences I mean um we're
not going to attend any of the events
you know the the concerts or anything
like that we're going to call them and
invite them to good invite them to come
to the Masid come let's go make let's
perform ha alhamdulillah let's you know
meet together benefit from each other
give each other advice advise one
another with the truth alhamdulillah
upon The Obedience of Allah if they ask
us about something of the religion we're
going to clarify them to them because
the truth is above all of us right it
doesn't matter who the person is the
truth is
universal so the thing about it with
regards to these individuals rappers and
people who were involved in the streets
also they have to understand the streets
are cursed I've said it many times the
violence whether it's the knife crime in
the UK whether it's the gun violence in
America if you're not fighting against
the culture is worthless because the
culture the prophet what did he
say this world is cursed everything in
it is cursed except for the remembrance
of Allah subhana wa tala and that which
is connected to it or a scholar or
somebody that's learning Subhan Allah
Subhan Allah so if you said that about
the D what about the
streets what about you know drugs worst
part murder Zena and all of the sh
that's connected to it even now if you
look at certain you know things aspects
of the street life now they're talking
about smoking on the remains of the
deceased that was killed their Ops
opposition their enemy going to the
graveyard you know digging
dead people because that was their enemy
when they were living and so on and so
forth you can see us connected to the
devil C
con from various different angles so we
have to you know clarify to them that
that culture is cursed there's no good
going to come from it and that in this
world they're going to be held
accountable for their actions and for
their statements in the want to be held
accountable all of us it doesn't matter
who you
are was the the AY I think
[Music]
was many times no thank for for the the
points he mentioned and all the adah
around them and I hope it's beneficial
for us and also for the for the for the
people um watching this and also
especially for the for the for the new
Muslims and maybe the influential
non-muslims as well and and just you
know our coincidence it's it's it's it's
something that's that's highly um you
know beneficial that that we we are
actually here in in a DA in in in K and
we have you know obviously one one of
the M from from
Kuwait here um you know going through um
um a book and and and various benefits
that he will be providing across across
the UK as as as a tour that he's doing
so um alhamd maybe you want to talk
about that a little bit as well um just
just to just to close off alhamdulillah
this is another seminar in M the is
visiting likewise Bristol slau
Birmingham visiting the mid and the
Maris alhamdulillah which shows the
growth you know and the spread of The Da
so many mid and Maris excellent efforts
you know all around the country you know
all over the world alhamdulillah and is
spreading may Allah subhana waala bless
it and Allah make us firm upon it until
we leave this world I think that's
important for us as well to appreciate
you know the spread in the grow of the
you know hundreds of people if not
thousands of people some of the seminars
no comedians you know no anid thousands
of people attending lessons to learn
what Allah said the prophet sallu Al
wasallam said the companions they said
this is how communities are built this
is going to
last you know if it's just about you
know camera moments for you know tiktock
you know an entertainment that's going
to pass there's going to be something
more popular entertainment or an
entertainment was more popular tomorrow
but it will remain and this is what
distinguish from other groups and and
parties
and and the meaning of which is
following the Quran and the Sunnah and
the way of the companions of the
messenger of Allah and their students
and their students is based upon subh
Allah the mention is about entertainment
bringing magician bringing
do a comedy show this Dean this is Dean
and
Allah send the prophets a Messengers to
teach people how to worship Him and
giving is
part Subhan Allah and as we have
mentioned has two conditions which is be
sincere and to follow the
of but now what we see people claiming
they doing da but they're turning da
into comedy turning da into a joke
turning da into
subh bringing magician doing tricks and
so
on and hiding behind what the
slogan do you not know that Allah sees
everything with is
dangerous whoever whoever introdu this
is something from our Affairs they will
be rejected and da you know Subhan Allah
so alhamdulillah I've been many times in
Cardiff Mah our brothers and sisters in
M doing a great job may Allah reward
them so we ask Allah to bless our I
think this second time yeah second I
think second time coming doing what
teaching the people teaching what as our
mentioned and the sah teaching them that
which will benefit them in this life and
Hereafter yeah and even the book He's
teaching I don't think it's being taught
before in English Allah knows best
according to my
it's known as
likewise some people say it's the same
title there's a bit of you know um
disagreement with regards to that but
the book itself alhamdulillah very
beneficial clarifying the belief and the
methodology of the people of the Sunnah
and M it's being translated into English
it's printed as well again showing the
spread of The Da and you got again like
hundreds and hundreds of people
benefiting you know here and also online
and seminars this is amazing you know
knowledge Brotherhood camaraderie
alhamdulillah this is you know the da of
the prophets and The
Messengers a blessing that's why some of
the he used to say you know if I saw a
man from the people of Hadith it was as
if I saw a companion of the messenger of
Allah s wasallam
may Allah subh bless us all to imitate
them and forgive us for our shortcomings
but just you know witnessing these type
of things you know alhamdulillah it's
not uplifting you know and it's a good
sign Allah subhana continue to bless the
da and protect it from fit and that
which is apparent and that which is
hidden a mean aan and insh we we'll
Endeavor to um post um those those
lectures online as well with so the
people that weren't able to attend can
can also can also benefit as well so um
um yeah for
that accept it and umah we'll see you on
the next one